the holidays will be different this year
it's still really important to remember
to recycle during this time jeremy
walters from republic services is back
with us
to give us his best holiday recycling
tips hey jeremy
hey rocky how are you i'm good how are
you
i'm fantastic holidays are here and yeah
they are a little different but yeah
right right and of course you know what
more can we do
let's help the environment at least 2020
right yeah
absolutely you know there are some
things that when it comes to recycling
some things fall on the naughty list and
something's on a nice list and we can
run through those today if you want
yeah let's do it so what can and what
cannot be recycled
yeah so let's start with probably the
most fundamental holiday things and
those are the gifts right
there are some of the wrapping uh
materials that are better suited for
recycling than others
so when it comes to bags or the wrapping
itself
things that aren't embellished with
glitter right we're talking just plain
paper
plain bags um you know not the ribbon
on the bag itself those are fine for
recycling but when they start getting
all those fancy embellishments like the
glitter
uh the bows uh the ribbons those things
can't actually go in the recycling bin
my family has a long-standing tradition
of reusing these things
these bows on the table i probably have
had them for decades you know we take
them out
we save them in a bag for next year
helps to save a couple bucks too
but i think simpler the better and the
more simple things can be recycled
other things that are more fancy
probably are better suited for some
reuse
so when you think about maybe cutting
down on your waist there are some things
that we can do as well and
maybe that's making the packaging part
of the gift itself so
you know basket like this you can get
the basket
and then they can recycle the tissue
paper then they can enjoy all the
contents
you know burlap bags they're all great
uh ways to get this and sort of that
out of the box fashion definitely and
i'm not sure if you said this but how
much
waste do people actually generate during
the holidays especially now that we'll
have you know smaller groups for the
holidays does that make a difference
yeah you know it could certainly make a
difference we see that on average
between thanksgiving and new year's day
that
people are making about 25 more ways
but the good news is that about 80 of it
can actually be
reused repurposed or in fact recycled
and so
after a lot of these things it's got to
be that decision on which bar
we use before we discard the items
definitely
and i do love to save bags especially
holiday bags you can use those for
anything right
oh absolutely i mean we have a closet
filled with
all sorts of reused uh and repurposed
gift wrapping
it's definitely a way to cut down on the
waste save some dollars as well
uh but those are some really great
recycling tips there are some other
things that we have to consider as well
and that's a performance right ornaments
uh you know my wife changes the
ornaments on the tree
all the time she changes her styles she
tries to keep up with the trends
and they are still usable but we can't
uh we can't mistake the idea of
reuse with recycling so don't throw
ornaments
or old christmas lights or even the tree
in the recycling bin those things are
uh you know they're best suited to go to
a second-hand store
they're so usable and maybe you just
have grown them your style has changed
but definitely don't place them in the
recycling bin
people don't think about that very often
so thank you so much jeremy we
appreciate that and i love your display
you're matching that
um you're watching that reindeer over
there alright so for more information
visit recyclingsimplified.com